When the beastly scourge crept into Yharnam
the people responded with: The Hunt, with iron and fire.
The populace ralied to purify this city; they fought alongside the hunters
who were talented warriors properly equipped to counter the beasts.
Together, you would've thought they had stand a chance yet when we arrive in Yharnam
something seems wrong. The Hunt continues but the populace has changed.
The line between man and beast is blurred and perhaps it was the bloodlust that the hunt inspired
that further awakened that beast within man.
The hunters become hated and feared for they turn into the most terrible beasts.
To prevent this from happening there has always been a hunter of hunters. A hunter with the resolve to hunt
former comrades who sucumb to their thirst for blood.
Hunters of hunters dress as crows to suggest sky burial. I quote: "They hunt with the hope that former compatriots
might be returned to the skies and find rest in the hunters dream."
Eileen is one of these hunters and she was likely recruited when the hunters workshop
was still in its infancy. She wields the blades of mercy, forged with syderite, which is a rare mineral of the heavens.
This weapon and Gehrman's Burial Blade are the only weapons of their kind.
They're masterpieces that defined the entire array of weapons crafted at the workshop
Eventually the hunters workshop was no longer needed but Gehrman went on to become the host of the
Hunter's Dream
and started to guide hunters into the waking world. Like us, and many other hunters, Eileen visited the dream too.
When a hunter of the dream dies in the waking world their conciousness retreats to the hunters dream
From here it seems that they can set out and brave that night again. With the dream to sustain her
Eileen must have been a force to be reckoned with; everyone needs something that they are good at
a skill, a talent. Eileens skill was that she had the control to resist the intoxicating effects of the hunt
and the ability to deal with hunters who where too far gone.
When a hunter gave in to bloodlust, Eileen would sweep in and kill him or her before they could do any more damage.
Her very unique hunts protected the other hunters from themselves and she did this task until her age caught up with her.
and even beyond that, because the Eileen we meet is very old indeed.
But one day she stopped dreaming...
Doll: "Over time, countless hunters have visited this dream. The graves here stand in their memory.
it all seems so long ago now. Farewell, good hunter, may you find your worth in the waking world."
Eileen: "No more dreams for me. This is my last chance."
So like many other hunters before her, Eileen was freed from the dream. Gehrman, host of the hunters dream
granted her mercy; but did she willingly or did she simply outlive her usefulness?
Whatever the case we might never know. Eileen remains in Yharnam and continues her hunt.
her purpose unfulfilled
Eileen: "Oh, a hunter are ya? And an outsider! What a mess you've been caught up in.
And tonight of all nights. Prepare yourself for the worst. There are no humans left
they're all flesh hungry beasts now."
Without the dream, Eileen's death is permanent, yet still, she remains in Yharnam: proud, undeterred and determined
To hunt down every last hunters that poses a threat. But Eileen is one of the oldest character we encounter
and without your help she will perish in any assasination she attempts.
Eileen: "That wasn't necessary of you, but you have my thanks. We made it with our lives, you're not bad at all.
You must've killed Gascoigne as well then... He was falling apart, im sure it had to be done.
But try to keep your hands clean; a hunter should hunt beasts, leave the hunting of hunters to me. [laugh]"
Her pride is untouched and she contnues to place herself in harms way...
Eileen: " Oh, is that you again? Im afraid I've made a bit of a blunter. Im just going to have a short rest.
Don't worry, i've taken blood, enough to save an old woman, but that thing still lies in wait.
Turn back, this is my score to settle."
Eileen's trail of assassinations, eventually leads her to the most powerful hunter in the waking world.
People call him The Bloody Crow of Cainhurst, but to Eileen he is likely a former comrade and possibly one of Gehrman's
first apprentices. Lets note three things about him:
1.  He wears the crowfeather set as Eileen does, suggesting he is or was a hunter of hunters.
2. He has mastered the art of quickening and dashes about with extreme speed; and this art is particular
to the first hunters of the workshop. Indeed we tease this art from a hunter's remains. Once this hunter was likely
an apprentice to Gehrman, one of the first.
3. The bloody crow uses the weapons and armor of Cainhurst, which is a far away land ruled by a queen
who craves the blood of hunters. He drops the blood rapture rune which resonates with servants of the queen.
Whoever he is, he seems to no longer see a purpose in hunting beasts. He and Eileen are not so different in that respect.
In fact, Eileen could just as easily find herself in his place if you don't aid her on her journey.
And, she does, she becomes almost like the townsfolk of Yharnam, who see nothing but evil when they look at another hunter.
Eileen: "The beasts cannot be stopped, what good are hunters now?! Your blood is mine!
"You monsters, all hunters must die..."
But you do aid Eileen and she doesn't lose herself. She lies here on the steps, bloodied and broken after her fight
To pass along her duty to another hunter.
Eileen: " Don't you ever listen to your elders? No matter. You did save my life. I don't seem to be up for this life anymore.
My glory day were long ago now. I know, here, for you, this too is hunters work. But it bears no honor.
The burden you may choose to carry, the decision is yours alone. Ugh, my eyes grow heavy. Let me rest a while."
After all this you should be questioning the hunt; many characters do. It's purpose is, of course,  to hunt beasts.
But it was the hunt itself that further awakened the beasthood within man
its unleashed the blood crazed hunters upon the world: men, women, who individually can do more damage
than any mere animal. And when all is said and done, when you have painted Yharnam with the blood
of its men and women who turned into beasts; who did you really kill for?
Is it really mercy that Gehrman shows to those who exit the dream? Or are we removed because we came too close to the truth...?
After all, once you wake, it's difficult to remember what you dreamed about...